good morning believe nation today's
message is be a great leader over to you
John you know weather vanes typically
our politicians wear whatever way the
winds blowing
whatever the mood of the moment is
whatever the polls say they spend that
direction
leaders are lighthouses there's a
consistency - there's a strength to you
know lighthouses are only needed when
the weather stormy and it's beautiful
they're just a pretty building but when
the seas are storming and it's dark and
rainy and foggy that's when you need a
lighthouse a leader has to be a rock
someone of consistency that when the
storms whether it's a business what the
economy whatever is happening to the
organization that you're over that
you're a human alka-seltzer you calm the
organization I mean I've worked for
people that were quote-unquote leaders
who you know would bring a bucket of gas
to a fire and make it you know just turn
it into a blaze by how they reacted to
it great leaders are commerce great
leaders are people that when maybe
everything is hectic and chaotic but
when people see them hear from them
they're calmer I believe a peaceful mind
generates power if you want to do
something great then you're gonna need
to build a team whether it's in business
whether it's some other movement that
you want to build if you want to do
something great you can't do it alone
you need a team and so many people go
through this as they're building their
business often they hire the wrong
person at the start and it doesn't work
out and they say you know what forget
this I'm just gonna go back to doing
everything myself and that is not the
answer the answer is to learn how to be
a better leader as your organization
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger your role the contribution you're
giving actually
diminishes if you had a hundred people
in your company the thing that you're
doing day in and day out is minor
compared to what your hundred of the
people are doing for you you know when
you're solo you're doing everything when
you bring on one person maybe you're
doing still 75% of the value is you're
the best at what you do but then as you
start bringing more people on your
contribution diminishes and so yes
you're focusing on what you can become
the best in the world at but your
greatest contribution is going to be
leading your team to help unlock their
potential and allowing them to be the
best in the world at what they do and we
don't go to school for leadership right
we don't really learn leadership in high
school we don't learn leadership in
universities no of course you can take
maybe you join a sports team and maybe
you had a coach who was amazing who
guided you but this isn't part of the
process for most people most people
aren't training in leadership this is
where I think understanding your one
word is really important when you know
what it is that you stand for then it's
way easier to leave a group of people
it's way easier to build a team of
people who are aligned with what you're
trying to do I believe great leadership
is about unlocking the potential and the
people on your team they're working on a
certain standard which may already be
high but you see the meaning with the
work up here and your job is to help
them close that gap through believing in
them through pushing them through
training them you have to help them
close that gap that's what I believe a
great leader does and the way to do it
the easiest way my experience is through
understanding their one word in their
credo understanding what drives them
they are giving you the tools to help
push them so for example somebody really
values creativity versus somebody who
really values grit hardwork and grit
versus creativity those don't have to be
opposites but it's something that they
really value and so yes we have
organizational goals here's what we're
trying to reach right I want to help
entrepreneurs I want to get to a million
subscribers it's our next goal we're
aligned around that but the people on my
team how do we go in the accomplish if
somebody really values creativity that I
need to push them on creativity I need
more creative solutions
I need creative editing I need creative
videography so we're
I need creative thumbnails and I need to
I need more creativity where somebody's
word is grit or as part of their Creed
it was grit that I need them to work
harder I need them to push themselves
if somebody's word is extraordinary that
how can we make this more extraordinary
what do we need to do I need
extraordinary some nails an
extraordinary videography I need
extraordinary editing I can't make
somebody who values creativity and push
them to extraordinary it's just on who
they are it's gonna be a it's gonna be a
disconnect so understanding what our
goal is having a common goal and then
giving people the flexibility and
freedom to go and help you accomplish
that goal in the way that best suits
them and you understanding them there
one word their credo they're giving you
the tools to push them they're giving
you the tools to close that gap between
where they're right now and where the
potential is which in my view is the
ultimate goal of a leader so the
questioning today is I'm curious are you
a leader and how many people are on your
team could be full-time could be
contractors I'm curious how many people
are on your team right now leave in the
comments below super curious to find out
I also wanna give a quick shout out to
Daniel Burgess Daniel thank you so much
for picking up the copy of my book your
one word really really means a lot to me
man and I hope you're enjoying the read
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning or another shot events
VESA
espresso give me go
my last paycheck I still remember it
clearly he was one of the worst and the
best days of my life and I was in Puerto
Rico I was in I was working for Xerox
and my boss gave me my last it wasn't a
paycheck was a bonus check I think was
about 30,000 bucks taxable it's the only
problem with that look at this check and
I went you know I mean so I was excited
but I was also disturbed and so this
other guy comes up to me they must John
and John says to me says you're gonna be
back I said why he says cuz you're gonna
fail I looked at him as a look few
expletive words because that's what he
did he left Xerox failed and came back I
said look you fail and you come came
back but I'm gonna fail and I'm never
coming back and that's the attitude do I
mean yeah if if you say well if I fail
I'll go back to mommy and daddy
then that's what you'll do so if you
fail that's when I became an
entrepreneur because I had no money I
had no money for years yeah I didn't
have a paycheck but that's what my rich
dad encouraged me to do is is when
you're when you don't have this paycheck
you get hungrier smarter and use a test
of your character we become a crook we
become dishonest will you cheat and
steal or will you become a better human
being so really that's the benefit of
becoming an entrepreneur you really find
out who you are when you don't have
anything if you're an entrepreneur and
you're going to be a big entrepreneur
leadership skills and communication
skills are more important than a law
degree so now I have another book that
just came out it's called the eight
lessons in military leadership and the
military I went the Military Academy and
all that I you know from day one you
learn in leadership you know day one at
the Academy I have to stand in front of
20 18 year old kids and go
section ten-hut and that's right there's
not legacy for true you you know so
that's when you learn to be a leader now
as you said to me when I first met but
filled with the military goal or rough
so I had a hard time when I came back
from Vietnam and I went to work for
Xerox and you know people don't like
that idea call him an [ __ ] enough
okay you know stuff like that
[Music]
this you know but they don't
oh I'm gonna call my HR person I prefer
I better make some changes here you know
I'm talking about of course you can't
talk straight in corporate America you
have to yeah yeah and I love it yeah you
know what you give promotions if you do
it well what when I got called names all
the guy likes me so that's why I follow
you guys for military veterans you know
you have probably the number one skill
to be an entrepreneur which is
leadership the ability to listen to not
take it personally and kill still get
the job done it is the best training in
the world you know the saddest thing
about beef in the military was leaving
the guys behind there there was some of
the best in the world and there were you
know there weren't all college graduates
there were just my Gunners my mechanics
you know all this stuff camaraderie
oh Jesus priceless it's all I did when I
when I started the Rich Dad Company was
to have that same sense of teamwork
insight rich debt that's why there's no
ranks and all this stuff in this company
everybody gets to say what they want to
say people are free to do what they want
I stay out of their way and we got the
job done everyone's not a leader and we
shouldn't expect everyone to be a leader
I think it becomes something that you
want to do or you born with it and some
people lead by example some people lead
by a voice some people leave by both and
for me I felt in order for myself to be
as good as I wanted to be and at the
same time in order for our team and be
as good as I wanted it to be I had to be
both as well as we play last game and it
gonna be enough to win tonight you gotta
give wardog y'all protect war you gotta
help warn you gotta sacrifice more in
order to get this win you have a lot of
different style this list let's throw
some of them you likewise teacher
sometimes I uh I got so like you see
it's me I got so many different
forms of leadership and it's discussed
my personality mm-hmm you know at times
I can be silly these beautiful boys got
me look alike at times I could be
serious if you know personnel you know
teammates you throw it up to the rim
that's like you thrown that same past
check would you say you want throw that
past the shaft the times I could be like
a teacher and be like you know focusing
in on all my students I could be the
student you know and to be able to have
different forms of leadership has helped
me because you have different
personalities in the locker room
everybody is not the same the way I'll
talk to d-wave may not be the way I can
talk to Chris or the way I'll talk to
Chris may not be the way I'll talk to to
UD or to bird or to real big time Big
Time everyone's personality is different
so my leadership skills has different
phases because I understand what I'm
doing sometimes you know the smile and
leadership sometimes the playful LeBron
sometimes you use that is a formal you
should yeah absolutely I got that from
being around not my childhood friends we
used to have so much fun and we
understood when that ball was tipped
this is we don't have the most fun here
and I just brought that with me
to the NBA when you're doing something
that way and it's working and you're
winning and you're not disrespecting the
game right you did this is what you feel
like is how supposed to be done it's
given me a sense of brotherhood and
that is hard to come by
[Music]